tout objectif sans plan n'est qu'un
souhait a écrit antoine de saint-exupéry
la dissertation n'échappe pas à la règle
tout dissertation sans plan n'est pas
une dissertation
oui mais il ya beaucoup de plans
possibles c'est à dire de manière
différente de structurer l'argumentation
alors laquelle choisir vous avez
peut-être déjà reconnu aristote je suis
romain vous êtes sur mille idées de
culture générale et aujourd'hui on va
parler dissertation
[Musique]
dans ma vidéo sur les vingt mots les
plus importants en dissertation
vous pouvez la voir soit en cliquant sur
le lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description dans cette vidéo et j'avais
promis de faire une vidéo sur les plans
la voici donc je prévois de faire
d'autres vidéos sur la dissertation
donc si ça vous intéresse et bien dites
moi dans les commentaires les aspects de
l'exercice dont vous aimeriez que je
parle par exemple l'introduction les
transitions les accroches etc bref dites
moi vos préférences dans les
commentaires vous pouvez aussi me poser
toutes vos questions et je répondrai à
chacune d'entre elles sans exception et
puis bien sûr donner un pouce bleus si
la vidéo vous plaît abonnez-vous et
activer la cloche des notifications pour
être prévenu de la publication de la
prochaine vidéo
ce serait bête de louper la dernière
vidéo sur la dissertation avant un ds ou
une épreuve
bon allez trève de précisions je vais
vous présenter les sept plans de
dissertation que je connais en allant du
plus utile ou moins utiles pour vous
épargner de prendre des notes
j'ai fait une synthèse des sept plans
avec des schémas
vous pouvez télécharger le fichier pdf
soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite soit sur
celui qui est dans la description de la
vidéo puis en me laissant votre adresse
email allez aristote s'ennuie déjà donc
on passe au plan
[Musique]
on commence avec le plan dit critique
il est extrêmement simple il comporte
deux grandes parties dont les idées
générales s'oppose la thèse et
l'antithèse la logique de ce plan c'est
d'alterner le jugement pour combattre le
préjugé en se plongeant successivement
dans les deux points de vue opposés qui
prévalent sur une question prenons comme
exemple le sujet de philosophie du bac s
de 2017 peut-on se libérer de sa culture
les candidats pouvaient faire un plan
critique très simple si la culture
détermine la manière dont l'individu
s'insère dans le monde
il semble toutefois capable de s'en
émanciper
le gros avantage du plan critique c'est
qu'il est très simple mais peut-être
trop simple pour vraiment traiter le
sujet ou même tellement simple qu'il va
éveillé la suspicion du correcteur au
lycée ou pour des épreuves courtes ça
passe mais je vous conseille de faire au
moins trois parties en dissertation
comme avec le plan dialectique
[Musique]
ce plan vous le connaissez probablement
sous la dénomination thèse antithèse
synthèse
mais le mot synthèse ne pose problème si
on y réfléchit bien ça n'a pas de sens
de conclure avec une position médiane
qui soit une synthèse des deux premières
parce que la vérité ou la sagesse ne se
situe pas forcément au milieu et puis en
pratique c'est une consigne très vague
pour construire la troisième partie ce
qui explique que le grand troyes et
souvent plutôt raté donc les trois
parties du plan dialectique sont plutôt
de thèse antithèse et dépassement est en
effet en philosophie la dialectique
c'est le mouvement de la pensée qui
oppose des contraires dans le but de les
dépasser
donc le grand troyes ne doit pas
mélanger le grand un grand 2 mai avancé
des éléments de réponse nouveaux qui ont
émergé grâce à la réflexion menée dans
les deux premières parties
si je reprends comme exemple le sujet de
philosophie du bac s 2017
peut-on se libérer de sa culture on peut
tout aussi le traiter avec un plan
dialectique comme si la culture
détermine la manière dont l'individu
s'insère dans le monde
il est toutefois capable de s'en
émanciper et il peut même en prenant
conscience qu'il en est
acteur la transformer le plan
dialectique
c'est de loin le plus utile et le plus
flexible au sens strict il doit
forcément commencer par la thèse
antithèse
mais en pratique la règle c'est que les
trois parties sont structurées par des
liens logiques opposition qu aux
conséquences addition illustration est
la plupart du temps un des deux liens et
d'opposition le plan dialectique est
particulièrement efficace en philosophie
et en culture générale mais il peut
fonctionner dans toutes les disciplines
son inconvénient au principal c'est la
difficulté à trouver cette fameuse
troisième partie je compte faire une
vidéo sur les manières de la trouvais
donc abonnez-vous et activer la cloche
de notification pour être prévenu de la
publication de cette vidéo
mais si vous voulez vous pouvez déjà me
poser toutes vos questions dans les
commentaires
allez on passe au suivant
[Musique]
le plan analytique consiste en trois
parties qui sont explicitement diriger
vers la résolution d'un problème il en
existe deux voire trois versions la
première c'est aspect causes
conséquences
la deuxième c'est aspect cause solution
on remplace les conséquences par une
solution et puis en mixant les 2 c en
donne une troisième aspect causes
conséquences solution la logique de ce
plan elle est inspirée de la méthode
médicale
le diagnostic gasperi cause le pronostic
les conséquences probables est la
thérapeutique
les remèdes le médecin constate les
symptômes de la maladie il en induit les
causes probables
il fait des hypothèses concernant
l'évolution du mal et enfin il prescrit
des remèdes aux passions si j'ai à
traiter un sujet d'histoire ou
d'économie à ces bateaux sur la
mondialisation par exemple je pourrais
faire le plan à l'analytique suivant
tout d'abord les aspects de la
modélisation les flux accru douchant 10
de capitaux et d'hommes ensuite les
causes de la mondialisation le progrès
technique
les réglementations etc et enfin les
effets de la mondialisation la
croissance économique les inégalités
l'interpénétration des cultures la
résurgence des nationalismes et c'est le
plan analytique et à ses pratiques parce
qu'il est très à l'emploi et transparent
pour le correcteur
après tout les sujets ne s'y prête pas
et puis il est assez mécanique pas trop
littéraire c'est pour ça qu'il est
surtout utile pour les épreuves courtes
comme les interrogations orales
[Musique]
le plan thématique comportent
généralement trois parties chacune
assigné comme nous l'indiquent un thème
particulier alors je reprends l'exemple
d'un sujet sur la mondialisation
on peut faire un plan thématique à
partir de la définition de la
modélisation comme augmentation des flux
de marchandises de capitaux et de
personnes s'adonnent en un
la mondialisation de l'économie
productive en grand 2 la mondialisation
financière et en grand trois la
mondialisation culturelle
le premier thème c'est l'augmentation
des flux de marchandises
le deuxième l'augmentation des flux de
capitaux et le troisième l'augmentation
des flux de personnes avec un plan
thématique c'est plus facile de
sélectionner les arguments et les
références né ce plan à plusieurs
défauts peu de sujet s'y prête
les thèmes à retenir ne sont pas
forcément évident certains sont plus
faciles à développer que d'autres et
enfin il est plus difficile de justifier
l'ordre des grandes parties c'est pour
ça que je ne suis pas fan du plan
thématique
[Musique]
ce plan c'est moi qui l'ait entre
guillemets inventé et qu'ils aient
choisi le nom je n'ai pas eu à chercher
bien loin
parce qu'il combine les deux plans
précédents chaque grande partie cible un
thème précis
non c'est là le plan mathématique mais
chaque grande partie correspond en même
temps à une étape de la résolution d'un
problème cela le plan et analytique
j'ai progressivement élaboré ce plan ou
par la pratique
à force des ses erreurs lors de mme
école de langues en prépa hec
étant donné l'actualité et la dimension
économique de la grande majorité des
sujets que j'avais a commenté je suis
arrivé à la structure suivante en
première partie et les symptômes sociaux
du problème en deuxième partie ses
racines économiques et en troisième
partie les solutions politiques
envisageable par exemple un sujet sur la
hausse du prix du pétrole pourrait être
traitée avec le plan suivant d'abord les
conséquences sociales du phénomène
ensuite ces causes économiques et enfin
les mesures politiques susceptibles de
le contenir
y'a pas grand chose à modifier en fait
alors la logique intellectuelle de ce
plan elle est un peu marxiste dans la
mesure où on part du principe que les
causes des événements sont de nature
économique
ça ça lui fait un défauts évidents qui
est laid que la grille de lecture
marxiste peut paraître réductrice autre
défaut ce plan convient surtout pour des
sujets d'histoire d'économie ou
d'actualité mais bon je les aime bien
quand même mon plan thématique
analytique parce qu'il est bien commode
pour les épreuves où on n'a pas le temps
d'analyser le sujet en profondeur
il est vraiment prêt à l'emploi et il
combine les trois dimensions
fondamentales de l'actualité sociale
économique politique telle que la
présente les grands médias
[Musique]
là pas de mystère le plan chronologique
comporte en général trois parties qui
relate des périodes historiques
successives
a priori il ne peut servir que dans les
matières qui ont une dimension
historique
je prends en exemple le sziget
d'histoire et économiques tombaient au
concours d'entrée d'acheter en 2017
l'entreprise peut-elle se passer de
l'entrepreneur moi j'aurais fait le plan
suivant si l'entreprise semblait reposer
sur l'entrepreneur lors des première
révolution industrielle
elle a pu ensuite s'en passer en ce
bureau qu'artisans au profit des
managers
jusqu'à ce qu'il reprenne un rôle de
premier plan à l'occasion de la
troisième révolution industrielle
vous pouvez remarquer que ce plan est à
la fois chronologique et dialectique car
les trois parties sont articulées par
des liens logiques d'opposition
les avantages du plan chronologique sont
sa simplicité sa transparence pour le
correcteur et puis le fait qu'il
facilite la mobilisation des
connaissances dans le développement de
la dissertation
après il convient un peu de sujet le
découpage des périodes peut ne pas aller
de soi et puis ce plan pousse quand même
on recrache âge du court l'enjeu de la
dissertation
c'est quand même de réfléchir
[Musique]
alors je n'ai pas évoqué le fameux plan
sciences po parce qu'en fait il ne
correspond à aucune structure précise on
sait juste qu'il faut faire quatre
parties en revanche quand j'ai préparé
le concours de l'ena je me suis
familiarisée avec un type de plan assez
particulier que j'appelle du couple ans
ena faute de mieux aristote il s'agit
d'un plan en quatre parties en un à leur
rappel des faits essentiels en b la mise
en balance des théories pertinente en 2a
le bilan des solutions mises en oeuvre
et enfin en 2b les pistes de solutions
futures
voici par exemple le plan que j'avais
fait en prépaiement pour le sujet
d'économie le protectionnisme est il
voué à disparaître ma première partie
c'était les mesures protectionnistes
caractérise encore le commerce
international
à l'heure de la mondialisation la
deuxième le protectionnisme peut être
légitime dans certaines circonstances
transitoire en deux a le libre échange a
progressé de manière discontinue avec
des reflux de protectionnisme et enfin
en quatrième partie les solutions
futures préférable au protectionnisme le
libre-échange peut encore progresser
grâce au développement des négociations
commerciales
ce plan et n'a à deux avantages
principaux d'abord il est prête à
l'emploi
même s'il ya un gros enjeu de
formulation et puis il combine
efficacement différents niveaux de
connaissance les faits les statistiques
les théories et les hypothèses après les
moins fluide que le plan dialectique il
demande une grande culture générale
il est prescriptif porté sur l'action de
telle sorte qu'il est principalement de
l'utile dans des matières comme
l'économie ou la science politique des
matières qui sont au concours de l'ena
mais bon je trouve que la structure de
ce plan est quand même efficace
et puis il ne faut pas hésiter à la
customiser en fonction du sujet du jour
si nécessaire parce que ça n'est pas la
nature du plan qui importe ce n'est pas
parce que c'est un plan ena qu'il est
forcément génial non ce qui compte c'est
la commodité du point
pour résoudre le problème intellectuel
de la dissertation
[Musique]
ça y est on a donc vu les sept plans de
dissertation vous pouvez télécharger la
synthèse des sept plans en pdf soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite soit sur celui qui est
dans la description puis en me laissant
votre adresse email alors ça peut être
bien de connaître les sept
mais autant en maîtriser parfaitement un
ou deux plutôt que d'hésiter entre les 7
et d'en maîtriser véritablement aucun
pour ma part je ne fais presque plus que
des plans dialectique parce que c'est
vraiment un plan tout terrain adaptable
à tous les sujets et à toutes les
disciplines
la seule limite c'est qu'il faut un peu
de pratique pour trouver des troisième
partie satisfaisante
et puis il faudrait aussi de la pratique
pour formuler efficacement le plan bref
c'est toujours pareil
la réussite récompense l'effort si vous
avez aimé cette vidéo mettez un pouce
bleus et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour
être prévenu de la sortie de la vidéo
suivante posée mois toutes vos questions
en commentaire et je répondrai à chacune
d'entre elles vous connaissez déjà
aristote je suis romain et vous étiez
sur milliers de culture générale
souvenez vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête pour progresser en
dissertation
[Musique]